[Music]
so we've got a great question from joel
on facebook and here's what joel asked i
got hit in the t-mobile data breach
earlier this year and i keep getting
weird voicemails and texts from random
companies should i be worried about id
theft that's a great question ken if you
didn't hear about this back in august
t-mobile had a data breach that affected
almost 50 million customers i think i
remember i think i remember seeing a
headline yeah so this is scary stuff a
lot of data breaches out there at some
point your life you're going to be a
part of a data breach i mean a lot of
major companies very scary really yeah
but here's the thing let me explain to
you and this will answer joel's question
a data breach is different from identity
theft so data breach just means that
your information was exposed so there
was a security breach and your personal
confidential information is out there
someone may have access to maybe your
birthday your email address maybe your
social security number your street
address things like that but it doesn't
turn into identity theft until someone
actually uses that private information
uh for their financial gain and i
experienced identity theft did you i had
uh someone opened up an att account a
verizon account under my name using my
nashville address but they did it in
boston with my social security number
and racked up seventeen hundred dollars
on what was this this was uh back in
2014. was it uh did they at least uh re
um when they stole your identity were
they like a six foot five i was hoping i
don't know they ever found the person
but here's the thing uh it was very
scary because you go this person has my
very personal information they used it
against me yeah to create this debt in
my name that's crazy obviously i didn't
have to pay it but they racked up
seventeen hundred dollars on both
accounts uh and the good news is i was
working at ramsey at the time i had id
theft protection through xander dave
gets that for all the employees but
here's some things that joel can do
because i think it's a it's a legitimate
worry to have i don't want you to get
paranoid about identity theft you can
sleep
sleep easy at night but here's some
things that you can do number one is
check your credit report what's really
interesting right now is the bureaus are
offering free weekly reports through
april 20th 2022. normally you can access
them once a year for free right now
they're doing it weekly uh through 2022
april 20th uh 2022 thanks to covet so
that's one thing you can do check for
any suspicious activity there another
thing you can do and i did this after
identity theft is freeze your credit so
call up uh contact the three credit
bureaus and make sure you freeze your
credit that's equifax experian
transunion what that means is no one's
going to be able to open up an account
because it's frozen you might have to
lift it temporarily right temporarily if
you're you know applying for an
apartment and there's a hard inquiry if
you need to do a check like that and
another thing you can do beef up your
password game right most of us we don't
we can't remember our passwords we use
the same one on everything oops and
that's a dangerous move is it because if
they get your your password for your
t-mobile account that might be the same
one for your email and now they access a
whole web of things and so make sure
you're using strong passwords uh use a
password manager james childs our
producer loves a good password manager
that's another thing you can do he does
he strikes me as a privacy nerd yeah
another thing have you heard of this
two-factor authentication
um is that the deal where
this is getting you have to get a cell
phone number well yeah so you can do
different things see smarty
you've got a password but you also have
to verify it through maybe a text
message
opening up a smartphone app or a
physical security key so those are all
great things but the number one thing i
tell you to do to sleep easy is just get
identity theft protection it's super
cheap for an individual it's you know
it's the cost of a latte and for a
family it's the cost of a pizza per
month to stay protected and what this
does this i didn't i didn't know this
xander does all the work for me they do
and so they're they're 24 7 365 support
and they will cover up to a million
dollars for stolen funds and expenses
and there's proactive monitor monitoring
and alerts so i love this i sleep easy
at night now i haven't had identity
theft since
and i do these other things you know i
freeze my credit i make sure my
passwords are strong and i use
two-factor authentication so that in
case of a breach it doesn't create
identity theft yeah i got to tell you
george i feel much better because when
you started off on this whole deal about
data breach i thought somebody was going
to break into the studio because some
guys in some black suits and you know
the aviator glasses it sounds very very
scary but i do recall that each month
you know i'm not a fan of email but i do
get an email from xander and i click on
it it tells me and they'll let you know
hey your email was compromised go change
your password here and i go oh thank you
zan i would have had no idea yeah so it
there's it's a great feature and there's
a lot of things you can do to protect
yourself don't freak out joel
but make sure that you're doing these
things good stuff good question thanks
george good stuff